more than 30 people have been killed and
over 100 more wounded after Russian
Rockets hit a train station in the city
of Kramer tosk in the Donetsk region the
station was being used by civilians to
escape to safer parts of the country
officials say thousands of people were
at the station at the time of the attack
the head of the regional Administration
posted these images on social media
showing dead bodies outside the station
officials say it's one of the deadliest
strikes of the six-week old war rescue
workers are on the scene
now let's bring ndw correspondent
Alexander phenomen who is in Keith at
the moment Alexander first could you
tell us more about what you've heard
about the Kramer tours railway station
attack
well according to Ukrainian authorities
35 people were killed and 100 so wounded
in a Russian missile attack on the train
station in crematorics we have to stress
that this train station is a very
important evacuation hub for people
fleeing the eastern part of the country
to be particular the donetska region and
for days now thousands of them have been
coming together there to get out and the
platforms of that train station were
jammed with people and we know that
targeting civilians is of course
prohibited by the loss of War so the
Ukrainian authorities have already
condemned the Russian missile attacks
however the Russian pro-russian
separatists in the region are saying
that it was just a Ukrainian provocation
they say that that claim that without
providing any proof for that the
European Union has already condemned the
attack as well and of course it's
devastating can use when we take into
account how many people were trying to
to get out of the region to to reach a
train to evacuate because of course all
of them are expecting a major Russian
offensive there now as Russian forces
withdraw to the east of the country one
assumes uh that leads to some gruesome
discoveries president zielinski said
that atrocity atrocities committed in
the now free borrowed Dinka are greater
than even in in butcher you visited both
places what can you tell us about that
well I have to say that when you arrive
at the town of borodianca you are just
shocked by the scale of the destruction
there there are high-rise houses there
they were almost completely destroyed by
Russian airstrikes and we still don't
know how many bodies are buried under
the rubble so it was shocking to all
members of our team to see the
discretion the destruction there but it
was also
heartbreaking to listen to What the
residents of this once so popular
commuter Town had to say about their
life under the Russian occupation but
judge for yourself here's our report
they have begun clearing the rubble but
any hope of finding survivors here is
long gone
borodianca lay on the main route of the
Russian offensive on Kiev the scale of
the destruction is so massive that even
emergency workers seem shocked
now we see with our eyes what the
Russians did to a peaceful town there
are no military bases here
they shot people dead bombed high-rise
blocks I don't understand why
when Russian planes drop their bombs on
the town in early March these apartment
buildings were demolished local
authorities fear that up to 200
civilians were killed their bodies still
buried under the rubble
in one of the blocks we meet Alexander
he is back to salvage some items from
his ruined apartment
when the Russian bombardment started he
managed to flee together with his family
it's better damn it I'm still wearing
the same clothes I had on when I left at
least I want to take some things with me
this used to be his children's room
I don't really know what to say don't
have words left they're bastards Putin
and his whole government
foreign
Aid among the residents lining up Nina
and her family
they lived through a lot during the
Russian occupation of their Hometown
including hunger and constant fear
were pointing their guns at my daughter
and the kids I went down on my knees and
screamed begging them not to rape my
daughter you know what can happen
many here told us similar stories Lena
says she's still shaking when she thinks
about the weeks under Russian occupation
we have to thank our soldiers they're so
brave they are so brave that they freed
our borrowed the anchor
look what they did to my town
but radianca was once beautiful and
green residents told us now it lies in
ruins the town is free but it has paid a
high price for for its freedom
a report about Alexander phenomenon
who's still with us in Kiev for example
the EU commission president
and they used top diploma Joseph Burrell
have arrived in Kiev today to meet
zelenski how significant is this amid
ongoing Russian shelling
I think that so this visit is
to be a highly symbolic gesture and it
is meant to stress Europe's unwavering
support for Ukraine according to the
European commission president and we
also know that the EU foreign policy
Chief has already announced that the
European Union will be providing Ukraine
with additional 7.5 million europes to
help the country investigate the war
crimes allegedly committed by the
Russian soldiers here however we also
have to say that we have seen prominent
visitors here before and this visited by
the European commission president is
coming quite late and the people I've
been spoken with speaking with here in
Kiev told me that they are getting
increasingly frustrated and disappointed
with the support that Ukraine is getting
from the European Union our
correspondent example phenomen there
reporting from Keith thank you Alexander
NATO member states have vowed to send
more military and humanitarian Aid to
Ukraine following their meeting in
Brussels on Thursday keeps foreign
minister made an impassioned plea for
help to fight off an expected Russian
assault in the East he told leaders of
the Western Alliance that Ukraine
urgently needs more weapons to head off
any fresh attack
the war in his homeland has been going
on now for 42 days so Ukraine's foreign
minister got a warm welcome at NATO
headquarters but dimitro kaleba didn't
make the trip to Brussels just to get
sympathy my agenda is very simple it has
only three items on it its weapons
weapons and weapons
so far individual member states of NATO
have been delivering weapons to Ukraine
like these Stinger anti-aircraft
missiles from Germany however two weeks
ago NATO members decided not to provide
combat tanks to avoid being dragged into
the war now the images of war crimes
have moved members to rethink that
was a clear message from the meeting
today that allies should do more and are
ready to do more to provide more
equipment and they realize and and
recognize the urgency the Czech Republic
has provided Ukraine with tanks and
armored personnel carriers Ukraine is
now pushing for other countries like
Germany to follow suit however German
tanks that had been taken out of service
first have to be overhauled its foreign
minister was non-committal we stand in
solidarity on Ukraine's side and that's
why we're also looking together at
everything that Ukraine would need in
order to better protect itself in future
after the meeting Ukrainian foreign
minister kuleba seemed cautiously
optimistic but complained that
everything's still taking too long
and here are some other news in brief on
the war in Ukraine
the United Nations General Assembly is
suspending Russia from its Human Rights
Council over the war in Ukraine it's
only the second time a member state has
been suspended from the council Moscow
has condemned the decision as
politically motivated and illegal
kremlin's spokesman Dmitry peskov said
that Russia has sustained quote
significant losses of troops in Ukraine
calling it a huge tragedy for Russia the
country's defense Ministry claims
between 1 and 2 000 Russian soldiers
have been killed but independent
estimates put the number closer to ten
thousand
a Nobel prize-winning a Russian
journalist has been attacked on a train
with red paint in an apparent protest
over his newspaper's critical coverage
of the ward Dimitri muratov is
editor-in-chief of the liberal Navaya
gazetta last week it said it was
suspending operations in Russia after
receiving official warnings